democracies at stake that is what i
heard from alexi danilov he is the
secretary of the national security and
defense council he was saying that world
leaders are talking about ukraine right
now and the threat that russia poses as
those soldiers and heavy artillery are
posed on the border with ukraine he is
urging world leaders not just to talk
about supporting ukraine but to actually
support ukraine by acting now and not
later on if something should happen for
canadians there was a very clear message
danilov said that he is grateful for the
government of canada's support and the
support of canadians however he said
that he has three requests for next
steps for canada and i'm quoting him
here when he said one defensive weapons
two defensive weapons and once again
defensive weapons at this point we have
not heard any commitment from the
government of canada to provide weapons
to ukraine we have seen other allied
nations do that the united states in
particular a third shipment of military
supplies just landed the other day here
in kiev the united kingdom has also
provided those sort of supplies but
canada has not as of yet canadians have
been contributing in terms of economic
support as well as the training of
soldiers and territorial guards and
border agents okay that has been through
operation unifier we're waiting to hear
details on the expansion or the
continuation of that operation but
really the ask right now in terms of
support from canada is those defensive
weapons
now the secretary made a point of saying
we don't need anyone else's soldiers
that ukrainians will defend ukraine
should it come to that and if that
actually happens he says
only vladimir putin has the answer to
that
crystal gamansen global news
keefe